A linked list is a common data structure
used in software development. It is also a
frequent topic in technical coding interviews.
In this course, Alvin will explain linked lists
and prepare you to use them both
in interviews and coding projects.
Hey, programmers, Alf Infrastruktur, here, welcome
to our course on linkless. What I want to do is
really get you well prepped for those linkless
problems on your technical interviews. So consider
this a little bit of a crash course, like I do in
all of our data structure and algorithm courses,
I want to go through two pieces of information
for every single problem. That is I want to really
draw things out visualize things and understand
the theory behind a problem before I go ahead
and implement the code behind it. Right, so we're
gonna do a one two punch for every single problem
here. So this is going to be an introductory
course on linked lists. So I'm going to assume
you know nothing about linked lists, but you're
not a total beginner to programming, right. So you
understand things like a while loops, for loops,
if statements and all that jazz, I'm also going to
assume that you know, a little bit of recursion,
because I'm going to show you some recursive
solutions for many of our linked list problems.
And so without further ado, let's jump right in.
So what I want to do is start by understanding
what a linked list is at a high level bird's
eye view. The first thing we'll need to know is
that a linked list is a type of data structure,
right? So we're organized as data. And in
particular, a linked list is made up of
many nodes. So as the first checkpoint here,
we need to first understand what a node is,
you can think of a node as just a container for
some data. So when we conceptually visualize
nodes, you really think of them as some
circles that I can put some data inside
here, I'll put a letter or character inside of
my node. But of course, you can store any data
you like. It could be a strings, numbers, Boolean,
or even other objects, right. And I'm saying that
a linked list contains many nodes. So let's say
had a bunch of nodes, and they can all contain
different pieces of data. So I have the characters
ABCD, stored in different nodes over here.
And if I wanted to make these nodes comprise a
linked list, then what I need to do is add some
links. In other words, if I have a node like a, I
can make it point to the next node, the dataset,
that is a points to B, right, can also say that
B points to C, and C points to D, right. And the
term we actually like to use for this is really
saying that A is next is B, right? It's going
to be very common linkless terminology, and a
pattern we're definitely going to see in the code
later on. And now you can already see why you call
this data structure, a linked list, right, have
a bunch of nodes linked together. The important
thing to note here, it's about the last node D,
right? D is the last node in our linked lists.
And so under the hood, we can really represent it
being the last node, by having its next pointer
pointing to nothing or more programmatically,
you can have its next set to null, right, the null
pointer and whatever your language of choices.
So sometimes during this course, I'm
going to explicitly choose to dry out
the null note or the null reference, just
so that we can build some very robust code.
Alright, now that we know what a linkless looks
like, I want to introduce some other terminology
that you're going to hear, right. So when we refer
to the very, very first node of linkless, that is
the a node in this diagram, I consider that the
head, it's a very common term. And a similar way,
we can refer to the very last node in a link list
as the tail, right. So if you hear those words,
in problems, we're referring to the first
node and the very last node respectively,
right? If you think about it, because I have this
sense of different nodes, and you know, a first
note and a second node, but you can think of a
linked list as an ordered data structure. In other
words, if I started at the head of the linked
list, I can just look at this nodes next pointer,
and I can go to the B node, so I can just
move to the right. And once I'm at the B node,
I can see that b has an X that goes to the C node,
and the C node goes to the D node, and the D node
goes to the null node, which must mean that I'm
at the end of the linkless. So that's a very,
very key characteristic about the linkless. Right?
A nice property to leverage about a linked list is
that it's an inherently ordered data structure,
right? If you want to refer to like the positions
of these nodes, and we do that programmer thing
of starting at zero, I can see that the head has
a position of zero, B has a position of one, and
then we just go sequentially throughout, right.
So there are four nodes within this linked list,
I can see that the position of the head is zero,
and the position of the tail is three. So so far,
we're probably not seeing the full value of the
link list, like when would this data structure
have some real utility over other data structures
that we know about? In other words, you're
probably wondering how a linked list compares to
an array because an array is also an ordered data
structure. So let's do that comparison right now.
So here I have my linkless up top, if I wanted
to represent you know, a similar data structure,
but in an array form, it would look something
like this, right? I have an array in memory.
And I know that that array has some indices,
right. So this is a really clear analogy here.
I know that the indices of an array correspond
to the positions of the nodes of a linkless.
Right. And obviously my link was is made of
many nodes. Whereas my array has many elements.
The most important difference between an array
and a linked list is that an array must be stored
contiguously in memory, that means all of your
elements in an array are going to be stored like
right next to each other in your computer's
memory. And that has a lot of consequences
in the runtime of different operations
across your array. Right? So let's say right,
now I wanted to step through a scenario, let's say
I have the goal of inserting a new element Q at
index two of my array. And the key specification
here is I want to insert Q at position two,
I don't want to overwrite the current element
at position two, right? So at the start of
this operation, I have four elements in my array
ABCDE. After I do my insertion of Q, I should have
five elements in my array, and they should go A B
QCD, right, because I'm inserting some new element
at index two. So how will this algorithm run at
a higher level in an array? Well, typically, all
you need to do is obviously find the index two,
which is right here. And I know that this is where
I need to put the new Q element, but I can't just
overwrite this value of C, because I want to do an
insertion not overwrite. And so what happens under
the hood in your programming language, when you
perform this insertion operation? Well, we hope
that there's still some empty space in the array,
and it should occur after D, right. Assuming that
there's still space in this array, I would need
to shift all of the elements to the right over by
one index. In other words, I need to put d to the
right, I need to put c over a one position to the
right. And now I have perfect room to add this cue
at index two. Right. And of course, now D would be
occupying a new index of four logically. But the
important step we took here was to actually
insert somewhere in the middle of an array,
that could mean that you need to shift over a
bunch of different elements in your array, right.
So in this very small example, I only had to move
over to elements of C and D. But let's say you had
a very long array, and there were, I don't know,
1000 elements after your insertion index, you
would have to shift all of them over one by one.
And that is a relatively costly and slow operation
for such a simple move of inserting Q, right.
So we say that when we insert into an array,
that does have an O of n insertion time, right, in
the worst case, if you insert at index zero of an
array, that is you're inserting a very first new
elements, you would have to shift everything over
by one index in the array. And since there are n
elements in the array you're doing and different
shifts. Awesome. Now let's compare that to a
similar insertion operation for our linked lists.
So let's say I still wanted to insert the value
of queue at position two of my link lists. Well,
that means I need to create a new node in
memory. And what's great about a linked list is
it is not required that the nodes are
contiguous in memory. In other words,
we can have these like nodes exist anywhere in
the space of our computer's a memory addressing.
And that's kind of a very low level statement. But
the consequence of this is I don't need to do any
shifting when I perform this insertion. In other
words, how does that work? Well, if I want Q,
to be composition to have my link lists, now
that I've created the new Q node, I just need
to adjust B's next pointer. So I'm going to
look at node B, and reset its next pointer
to point at q, then I set Q's next pointer
to point at C. And with those small changes,
I've actually changed, the logical order of
nodes within my linked list would now be this.
Right, queue occupies position to see occupies
position three, and so on. And what's really
great about this is, let's say that there
were many nodes after my insertion position,
let's say there were 1000 nodes, but wouldn't have
to actually modify all 1000 nodes that came after
my insertion point, I just need to change about
two pointers every single time. Because that's
a constant number of operations. I will say that
a linkless insertion, if we write it correctly,
will be constant of one time. So here we see
a very tangible difference between our linked
list data structure and our array data structure.
And there are many more a different pros and cons
between these two. But for now, we'll leave it
at that and we can chat more about them as we go
throughout the course I'm sure it's going to come
up. But what I want to do for now is talk about
the core core core, a linked list algorithm
that's just traversing through a linked list.
In other words, how can we just touch and
process every node within a link lists?
Well, the important thing to know is if you wanted
to, like give a link list to someone or in other
words programmatically pass a link list into a
function, you really only need to pass a reference
to the head node of a linked list. Because
if I give you the head node of a link lists,
by accessing the next property of every
node, you can have access to the full
sequential list, right? And so to actually
implement a traversal algorithm on a list list,
we just need a handful of variables. Most
importantly, we need like a current variable,
a current reference to look at the current node
of the linked list we're iterating through,
right. So if I have this current node of A, and I
want it to go to the next node, I can just look at
current dot next, right or something similar
in the programming language of your choice,
I can just set current equal to current dot
next, then I would be at the B node. And B also
has an XT. So I do that again, at the C node,
I can just keep continuing this process, right,
assigning current equal to current dot next,
until at some point, once I'm at roughly the tail,
current would be D. And so current dot next would
be this null node or this null reference. And if I
set current equal to next, I'll be right at null.
And that can be a perfect condition I can catch.
In other words, we can stop the algorithm when
current is equal to null, we know that that
point would have visited every node of the link
lists. So as I went through this high level trace,
I was kind of speaking upon this algorithm as if
it was an iterative solution. And I'll also show
you how you can solve this one recursively, it's
really the same line of thinking. At this point,
I would want to actually hop into some code. So
we can see the nuts and bolts implementation of
a link list as well as the core traversal
algorithm through a linked list. Alright,
let's do this. So here I am, in my text editor,
I'm going to be doing this in JavaScript,
although you shouldn't be able to follow along in
your language of choice. So the first thing I want
to do is just manually build a linked list. And to
start, I'm going to need to create a node class,
right, so we're gonna stay a little bit
object oriented here, just create a node
class. So from JavaScript, I need to give it
a constructor. And in terms of the properties,
we're going to need to store inside of an instance
of Node, I only need two things, I need to store
the actual value. But I also need to store a
reference to the next node in the linked list,
if there even is an x node, right. So to my
constructor, I'm just going to take in the value,
so I can say this dot val equals Val. And I'm just
going to always initialize my next to be null,
right, I can just manually reassign this next
property. And if you have this class or in it,
that's all you need to start creating some
linkless. I'll be it manually. So let's say
I want to construct a linkless, I'll just create
a few instances of nodes, I can create node A,
make it a new node, I need to pass in the value to
be constructed, I'll just give it some characters
here, maybe some capital letters this time. So the
character a lot create a bunch of nodes like this,
it's will have my B, my C and my D. I'll give them
some corresponding values. Naturally, I'm storing
strings or characters within the values of my
linkless. But you can make them you know, numbers,
if you want, it's no big deal. What I want to do
now is actually link these nodes together, that
way, I can just have a linked list, I can start
writing a few algorithms on, right. So typically,
this part would be kind of taking care for you
already. If you're on an interview, you can assume
that you're taking in a properly structured link
lists. But if I want to just like test some code
for myself, what I can do is say things like A's
next is going to be equal to the B node, right.
So I'm making A's next property, now become the B
reference. So I'm actually linking these two nodes
together, right? A's next is pointing to be the
same way, these next is pointing to C, C's next is
pointing to D. And there is no other nodes in my
linked list, I'm going to leave D alone. Because
I know automatically, these next would currently
be pointing to null, which does represent the tail
of my linked lists. So like visually, I think
of this sort of structure, I have a is my head,
that points to B, which points to C, which
points to D. And technically, D points to like,
no, so I'll be explicit here and just draw
that one out. Nice. So now that I have my
link list ready to go, let's go ahead and write
our traversal algorithm on it. That is I just want
to iterate through every node of the link lesson,
maybe just print out the value, something very,
very foundational here. And so all maybe choose to
make this its own function, I think that'd be the
best way to go about doing this. So I'll create
a nice function here, I'll call it just print
linked list, it's going to take in the head of
olink list, I'm going to stay kind of abstract
here. And I just like to call it head, right.
There's my nice empty function. And in terms of
how I would actually want to call this function,
the client would have to call print linkless.
And give it like the real head of the link list,
which for me in my little example here is just a
reference to the a node. Cool, so I'm actually
receiving the head node, which is an instance
of Node as the head of my link list here. And
so let's go ahead and now set up our algorithm.
So we're gonna really just implement the
algorithm we just traced out on the whiteboard.
So if I want to just traverse through a link
less and print out every node, I'm going to need
to continually update a current pointer. So I'll
say current equal to the head of the link lists,
which means I'm really starting at
the very beginning of my link lists.
And then from there, how far do I need to go
while you want to keep running this algorithm
while your current pointer is not equal to no,
right? Because if current is not equal to null,
then there's some stuff to still iterate through.
And now we get into the meat of the algorithm.
If I wanted to, like print out or process my
current node, I'll just console dot log here,
we're going to print out this current nodes value.
Right. And notice I'm writing all this logic in
terms of current, because I hope to update current
properly at the end of every iteration. Right. So
now that I printed out current vowel, what I want
to do is update what current is pointing to. So
what I should do is set current equal to current
dot next. And don't be fooled here. This is a very
simple variable assignment. Right? So let's run
this code. And then I promise that I'll trace
through how this actually operates. It's very
short code, but really the foundation of most
linklist algorithms. So let's give that a run
over here. I hope to print out my characters
ABCD. Awesome. And there I have them. So how does
this code work? Well, let's try to update and
annotate this drawing as we step through the exact
code here, right. So I know that in the context of
my function over here, I'm really only going to
track a really important variable of current. And
that starts at the head of my linkless, which
is passed in as the a node. So technically,
give myself some room here, I would say that
the current variable starts by referencing
the A note, so I'll kind of represent like
that it's aligned horizontally, right.
Cool. And what I want to do now is consider my
condition. So my condition is checking right?
While this current variable is not equal to
null, then run the code inside of the while loop.
So if I check that on the first iteration of that
condition is true, right, current is not equal to
null. So I can run the code inside, which means
I just print out the value of the current node.
Right? Since current is an instance, of node,
when I do console, log current dot Val, I will
be printing out the A that was initialized inside
of it. So that gives me my first iteration.
Now here's the important part. Right? Now,
I know that current is A, so in this moment,
that means current dot next would be actually
referring to the B node. So if I set the current
equal to current dot next, it has the effect
of literally moving this over to the B note.
Now I can check my condition again, is current
not equal to No, that's true. So I print out my
current value of b, and then go to the next. At
this point, the process just continues, right?
The C note is still not equal to null. So
I print it out over here and go to the next
node of D. And this is still true, right? D is
not equal to the null. And so I print out D.
And I actually proceed another iteration,
right. So right now current is D,
current dot next is null. So this would
literally happen, I set my current equal
to no. But things work out great here, because
when I check this condition, I'm going to check
is current not equal to null, in other words, is
no not equal to null. And that's false. So I exit
my while loop. Right. That's how I'm able to print
out every node of my linked list, right ABCDE.
So I think something to draw your attention
to right now is how we write this condition.
I think the best way and the most robust way
to write this code is to check while current is
not equal to null. The most common mistake I see
people make is they don't like generally that your
condition should be about like roughly the tail
of your link list. And so they might try to say,
well, current dot next is not equal to no.
Right. But that would actually cut your iteration
short. If I ran that, I would only really print
out ABC, right? Because when I'm at the D node,
right, I would be checking all right, before I
even print out D. What's these next? Well, these
next is no, so I won't even print out D, which is
bad, right? So generally, when you try to write
your algorithms, especially about linkless, try
to write it as like present as possible, right.
So I'm not going to do any premature checking of
the next node, unless I really, really have to,
instead, it's better to actually go to the
next node, and then exit when you actually
are at the null pointer, right, the null node.
So let me return this back to its former glory.
And we'll just make sure that this still works
is our classic implementation of a linkless
traversal. It's going to be the baseline code for
almost all of your linklist algorithms. Let's take
this a step further. And I'll show you how you
could write that same logic, but recursively
it's really the same logic, you just turn it into
a recursive call and a base case, right? So let's
go ahead and do this one together as well. When I
promised in the next section, I'll give you a nice
problem to work through. And so if I want to frame
this one recursively What do I need to do? Well,
I like to start with my base. case, your base
case should basically be an analogy for like the
condition you wrote inside of your while loop. In
other words, when are you done with the algorithm?
Well, I'm done with the algorithm once. I'm
looking at No, right? So I'm going to say, if head
equals no, then I'm done. So just return.
Notice that here, I'm keeping this argument
named as head, because I think of a link list
as containing many linked lists. In other words,
A is the head of this link lists. But if I look
at the sub list inside B, is the head of its own
linkless, as well, right and see, is the head of
a smaller linkless. Still. So I think that's okay,
terminology to use for a recursive function really
shows that you're buying into the recursive nature
here, right? Awesome. So I'm going to stop running
and just return out, once my head is looking at
null. So that'd be once I'm at this point, right.
But in the recursive case, what I want
to do is actually process this node.
So if my head is not equal to null, right now,
then I'm over here, right? What I should do is
just print out this nodes value, right, just like
I did before, I'm just reframing current data set.
And if I want to actually progress to the next
node, like I did, in my iterative solution,
I just do a very proper recursive call here.
So I'm going to call the same function actually
makes it recursive. And what should I specify as
this argument? Well, I just want to give the next
node in the linked list, right, so I'm passing
in head dot next. And that would be all I need
to do for this one, very, very short and to the
point. So let's run this recursive function,
then I'll help you trace through it a little
bit more awesome. So it's working, the trace
looks almost the same. But I think it's good if
we do it side by side with the code over here.
And really, the key argument we need to trace
through is the head over here. So on our top level
call, really passing in the a node as head. And so
I checked my base case here is head equal to null,
that's false. So I go into this console dot log,
which means I print out the value a, awesome,
and now I make a recursive call upon the next node
in the linked list. So if head is a, then head dot
next refers to B. And since I'm making a call to
that next node, in this next stack frame, head is
B. And I check the condition again, is b equal to
no, that's false. So I just print out b over here,
and then make another recursive call on B's next,
which is C, right? And this process continues,
all the way down to let's say, a when head is D,
right? I check this condition is d equal to no,
that's false. So I go ahead and print out D, which
is like the last logical node in my linked list.
And I would make another recursive call upon DS
next, right? So of head is D, head next is no.
And I would indeed make this call. And now I'm
back inside of this new call, and I check his
head equal to null. And that's definitely true
right now. So I return, that's my base case.
And I end my recursion, right, this base case,
is really, really important. So I want you to
compare and contrast, these two pieces of code,
they really implement the same algorithm. And as
we go through these linkless problems, sometimes
I'll show you both ways to solve it. depending on
you know, what style of problem you're solving,
you might find the recursive or the iterative,
a little easier to write over the other, which is
why I think it's important to practice both, but
maybe, you know, choose a favorite and decide what
you're most comfortable with. But that being said,
practice both. Alright, let's head back into the
whiteboard. Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right.
And I want to go over a approach for this link
list values problem. So hop right in right here,
this problem is going to be given the head node
of a linked list we want to do is return an array
containing all of the values within the nodes
of that linked list, we should do it in order.
Bear in mind in this problem, we're given a Singly
Linked List, which means that every node has a
pointer to the next node in the linked list, we
know that the last node of the linked list would
have a next pointer that points to know that being
said, how do we go about solving this one? Well,
there's problems, we're just going to have to
force you to implement a really core linkless
pattern that is just traversing through a linked
list in order. And so we'll start by attacking
this one, maybe with an iterative description.
So let's say we started from ground zero,
right? So we want to create our values array, and
to the side, we can just initialize values to be
an empty collection. And to implement this core
pattern of just traversing through a linked list,
we're going to need a variable or just a
pointer. And we're going to start at the head
of the linked list, right? Bear in mind
that our function only takes in the head,
but I know the head is like the ultimate starting
point of the linked list. And eventually I could
access everything throughout the entire list.
So I'm going to set my current equal to the
head. And what I can do off the bat is just check
current value and add it to my running collection.
So I have the a value inside of values now And
since I have access to the current node, I know
that if I access its next property, I would have
access to the next node of B. So what I can do is
set current equal to current dot next, basically
just moving my pointer to the next node like this.
Same thing as before I can add my
current value into the collection,
I'll just proceed in this way, right, same
thing for C, set current equal to current next.
And things get interesting once we
approach the tail of this linkless.
So I'm currently at the D node. And I go
ahead and add that value into my values list.
Well, we'll have to do now is consider the
scenario when it's appropriate to actually
stop our traversal. Well, bear in mind that these
next actually points to know. So maybe I'll draw
that explicitly just for this drawing. So these
next is just pointing to null. Which means if I
continue this algorithm in the general sense, so
I set current equal to current next, that means
my current pointer now points to know. And I think
that would be a perfect stopping condition. Right?
So once current is no, we know that we've hit the
end of our link list. And so we're totally done.
And if you look at the order of our values,
it is indeed the correct order, right?
What can we say about the complexity of this
algorithm? Well, if we say that n is just the
number of nodes in this link lists, then
the time complexity is going to be O of n,
right? Because we're just are really iterating
through every node once. And our space complexity,
if we consider the output right now would just
be also linear in the number of nodes over here.
And I'll tell you what this looks like a pretty
good strategy, we can go ahead and implement
well implemented in two ways. First, I'll show
you the iterative version, and also show you how
to implement this one recursively. Really,
both the iterative and the recursive code
use the same sort of mechanisms. So
I'll see you in the walkthrough video.
Hey, programmers, Alan here, right now want to
go over a JavaScript solution for this linklist
values problem. So we'll jump right in. And we'll
start by implementing, I think, the iterative
version that we spoke about in the approach video.
So if you haven't watched the approach video,
definitely make sure you check that out first,
right. And so I'll get the ball rolling over here,
what I want to do is use a pointer really just a
variable for me, right, so I'll say let current,
I'm going to initialize it to be the head. And
I know that though, most important pattern I
probably need for a linked list is just a
traverse in order through a linked list. And
the way that looks is I want to keep iterating
while my current is not equal to null, right,
so just not equal to null, no would mean the
very, very end of my linked list. Nice and very
standard code I need inside is to progress to the
next node of the linked list. So I said current
equal to current dot next. So now think about
actually generating the return type. For this
function, I do want to return an array of all the
values. So I should initialize that up top, I'll
say let's, or maybe const values, because an empty
array. And then as I actually iterate through all
of my nodes of the linked lists, at the tippy top
of this while loop, I can just take my current
nodes value, right, every node has a dot Val and
also dot next I'll take the current nodes value,
and just push it into values, right? So values dot
push, that single Val. And once this while loop
is done running, I must have hit the end of the
linked list. So I can just returned the complete
values array. So before we run it, one thing I
want to always emphasize is for your link list,
a main logic, it's always important that you try
to write your logic about just your current node.
So for example, my condition is saying, while
current is not equal to null, it doesn't say like
while current dot next is not equal to no, right,
you can probably get away with finessing code like
that, but ends up being more clunky than anything.
In other words, whenever I try to write my logic
for linked lists, I always try to stay very
present, right, so just worry about your current
node. So what I don't like to see is patterns
like this write current dot next dot Val, and try
to just shift your frame of reference because if
you do that, then you're actually kind of assuming
that your linkless has a particular length.
So instead, I always try to write all of my
expressions about simply current, right, so
while current is not equal to null, then I
push current dot Val. And then I can just update
current to be current next. And I can be assured
that every node is going to be processed in this
algorithm. So let's give this a test run now.
And if all is well, we can transition into the
recursive version now. Awesome. So how can we
do this recursively I'll just do that down below.
So the way I would structure this one, just so I
get the most optimal complexity is really with two
functions. So my main function will do almost the
same thing. It is going to call a helper function.
I'll call this helper function, maybe fill values.
And this function is going to actually do the
recursion. So it's going to take in the head of
the linkless, and also a reference to the values
array. So recall that in JavaScript if I pass
any non primitive types, so basically, things like
arrays and objects, they are going to be passed by
reference, right? So what I want this fill values
function to do is to actually mutate the values
array, because this main function is going to
return it. So what does that recursive function
look like? So we'll say fill values, it's going
to take in the head, and also the values, right?
I'll start with a base case here. And really,
what we're trying to do is just translate the same
patterns from the iterative code just into their
recursive variations, right? And so I know I need
to stop my recursion, once my head is no, right.
So I'm going to check if head is equal to null,
then you can stop. So just simply return, right
really important distinction here is, you're going
to have a tough time and probably end up with some
clunky code, if you say, if head dot next is null,
right. So again, I always try to stay very
present, and all of my code, so don't worry about
your next node, just handle yourself, right?
Eventually, every node will get served here.
So if head is null, then nothing much to do just
return and you can stop your recursion. Otherwise,
I know that head is not null, so it must be a
node, I need to take that nodes value and add it
to values, right. So I can say, head dot Val, and
I want to push that into the values collection,
right, we're call that values is referring
to this outer array here. But beyond that,
besides this current head, there could be other
nodes right in the remainder of the linkless. So
I can just call recursively fill values, and
instead of pass along head again, I need to
pass along head dot next, right. And that means in
that recursive call and kind of jump back around,
and now head is referring to the next node, and
so on, and then its value is going to be added
all the way until we get to the very, very last
node. Technically, after D, we would hop to
these next, which is no, in which case, we would
exit due to this base case, exactly. And before
we run it, just a few issues that I need to
fix, I see that missing an equal sign here.
And also when I call filled values, of course, you
need to pass along the same values array, because
I know that every call wants to add its value into
the same values array there. So we'll give this a
test run. See what we get. Cool. And now you also
know how to implement this algorithm recursively.
So the reason I like to split up my recursive
version for this algorithm into two functions
is so my recursion doesn't actually have to create
like multiple arrays, right? Instead, all of these
recursive calls are just adding their values to
a single array. If I actually created like copies
of arrays all the way through the recursion,
I would end up with like an n squared, sort of
runtime. Cool. So when it comes to comparing these
two implementations, they're actually equivalent
terms of their time and space complexity, right?
All right, programmers. That's all I got for this
JavaScript walkthrough. I want you to practice
both the iterative and recursive versions,
because they're gonna both be very useful for
the next upcoming problems. I'll see you there.
Hey, very amorous. Welcome back. Right. Now I
want to go over an approach we can use for this
some list problem. So in this problem, we're
going to be given a singly linked list containing
numbers as the values, what you
want to do is return the total sum
of all the values in the linked list. So for this
particular input, we should return a total sum of
20. And so how can we go about solving this really
just reviewing a core linked list pattern, right,
all you have to do here is just traverse in order
through the link list, and you can accumulate a
sum. So let's say we start from the beginning.
If we initialize some some variable to zero,
we can also just use a pointer that starts at
the head of our linkless. And what we can do is
we can take current value and add it into our sum
just updating the sum. So I take my current value
of to add it to my sum, by total sum is right now
to that I can set current equal to current next,
I can add this eight into my sum getting 10. next
iteration, I can add my three into the sum getting
13. next iteration, I can add seven into the some
getting 20. Alright, and I know that technically
seven does have a next pointer, and it does point
to null. So let's say I do that out explicitly.
What I can do at this point is actually continue
my algorithm. And I can make the stopping
condition when my current points to null, right.
So in general, we can call this up by saying a
loop like, you know, while current is not, no,
we talked about the complexity of this algorithm,
it's pretty straightforward. We're definitely
just iterating through every node. So if n is
a number of nodes, we have O of n time,
roughly one iteration of for every node,
and then our space complexity here is actually
o of one if we do this iteratively, right. The
only variables we need to maintain are really just
current and also the sum variable and we're just
going to store some primitive values in there. So
we have a nice constant space solution over here.
So the internet It was really straightforward.
Just for, you know, complete understanding how
can we solve this one recursively. If you saw that
recursively, that means you have to, you know,
call your function many times, and we start
with a top level call on the head node of two.
And what this should do is really just call upon
the next node, right? So I could call upon head
dot next session, give me a call to this eight
node, and that should call upon the three node,
and that should call upon the seven node.
And finally, the seven node should actually
call upon its next, which would be the null
node. And that will actually act as my base case,
I think it's a really great one, where I can do
with this base case, right? If my node is null,
then I can just return zero, right? Think of no as
if it's an empty linkless. What is the total sum
of an empty list? Well, that would definitely be
zero. So I'm going to plug in this return value,
right? So I'm saying this call to the null node
is going to return zero. When we say return, that
means returned to your caller. So the zero would
actually be returned into the seven node, what
the seven node should do is at its current value,
write its own value into that number, giving seven
and then that returns up the stack. At this
point, I returned back to the three node three
can add its value with that seven getting 10 Just
returning that up, eight can do the same giving
me 18. And finally, two can add itself into that
return value giving us 20. And that would be the
correct answer, right. So there are plenty of ways
to implement this one. If we solve it recursively,
we're definitely going to have one call for
every node within our linked list. So that'd
be O of n time. And the space complexity would
actually be a little more than our iterative,
we would have O of n space here because of the
call stack. Right? Typically, when we analyze our
recursive functions, we should include the space
utilize for making these recursive function calls,
right? So O of n over here. And notice that
when we bought them out at our base case,
we would have you know, roughly like four or five
things on the call stack. Alright, so those are
the two strategies, I'll think well code up,
and I'll catch you in the walkthrough video.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right, now I
want to go over a JavaScript solution for this
sum list problem. So I think we'll get things
kicked off by implementing a iterative version
for this. So I know I want to create a sum and
add to it over time. So I'll create that variable,
I'll say, Let's sum equals zero, I know by the
end of this function, I'm just going to return
that total sum. Now I need to lay down my very
standard code for just traversing through a linked
list. So I'll say let current, we're going to keep
updating this variable over time. And it's going
to initialize with simply the head node. And I
know that in the loop for this kind of classic
linkless traversal, I just want to iterate a while
current is not equal to null, right? If it's not
equal to null, then it's a node so I can actually
look to its next pointer. So I'm going to need
this pattern, right set current equal to current
dot next, this actually steps through, you know,
the link list and sequence. But how do I actually
want to utilize my current nodes value? Well,
I just want to take it and add it into the sum,
right? So sum plus equals current dot Val. And
eventually, once I hit the very, very end of the
linkless, I know current is going to be equal to
null. So I exit the while loop. Now just return
my total sum. So let's run this. Just a little
variation off of our last problem, just doing
some computation along the way. Nice. And now
I think I'll show you the recursive version, which
I quite like. So for your recursive version, it's
all about starting with a meaningful base case,
right? So first thing you think about is alright,
typically, for my linkless problems, my base case
is about my head being null, right? And that kind
of represents the scenario where my linked list
is an empty linked list, right? If it's null,
that means it has no nodes. So what's the total
sum of an empty linked lists while it's just zero,
so I'll check if head is equal to null, then
just return zero? It's important I think about
compatible types here, I know, when my linked
list actually contains some nodes, then I should
return a number. And even in the base case, I
should return a number. It's just the case that
I return the number zero. Nice. Let's say now we
write a recursive code, right? If the head is not
no, then it's actually a node. So I can look
at its value, right? Because the head dot Val,
what I want to do is take that number and add it
to the sum of the remaining nodes in the linkless.
How can I get the sum of the remaining nodes
after my current position? Well, that's just about
calling your function recursively. Right? And
passing along head dot next, right? So always try
to think about your recursive call for the type
of data that it returns, right? It gives me back
a number representing the total sum of everything
starting at the next node. I'll take that number,
add it to my value, and that should give me my
complete sum. So I'll just return it So I'll
give this a shot. And the recursive code is quite
short. One thing we should consider though, when
it comes to like an apples to apples comparison
between the recursive and the iterative, um, they
both have the same runtime, right, they both
have O of n. In the case of my recursion, I have
N calls in the case of my iterative code I have
and just iterations in the while loop. But the
recursive version also uses n space, right? That's
because for recursion, we actually have to add
every function call onto the call stack. So
I know by the time that my recursion bottoms
out a base case, I would have n calls on the call
stack. Whereas in the case of our iterative code,
we would actually use only a constant amount of
space because we only use a handful of variables
here. That being said, I highly recommend that
you practice both of these solutions, because
depending on the problems that we solve, you may
find a one more natural to use than the other,
hey, programmers, before we continue the course on
linkless, I just want to make you all aware of my
own data structure and algorithm platform that is
struck the dotnet. If you haven't noticed already,
all of the content that you're launching in this
course, as well as some of my other material on
Free Code Camp is also on structure dotnet, with a
lot of other topics covered as well. So we go into
the course, I cover all of those classic, you
know, data structure algorithm topics with tons
of videos for every single one. So if you
like my teaching style, I think you'll also
enjoy structure dotnet. And if you hop into any
particular problem, I'll give you a quick little
tour over here. So if we go to this insert, no
problem. Like you expect, you can write your code,
you can view the problem, you can run your
code, see the output, I think most importantly,
what will bring you the most value is my kind
of signature videos, right. So you're going to
be able to have a high level approach for
every single problem as well as the code
walkthrough. So you get the nuts and bolts code
implementation for every single problem. And even
still, if you're not like a JavaScript, I know
that this free coke and video is in JavaScript,
you can totally switch the language. So for all
of my C++ people in the crowd, doing so is that
is switching to C++ would obviously change the
prompt in the text editor. But also, you'd get
different videos right here you see a C++ specific
video over here, right. So if you've been enjoying
my content, and just want to check out more
data structure and algorithm material with me,
head over to structed dotnet. I'll leave a link
to the platform in the YouTube video description.
And with that, let's head back into our linkless
course. Hey, programmers, welcome back right now
I want to go over the approach we can use for this
link list find problem, and I'll show you two ways
to solve this one. So in this problem, we're going
to be taking in a linked list as input. And we
also have a target value we want to do is return
true or false whether or not the target value
is contained within the link list. So for this
particular example, I'm asking for a target of C,
you should return true because C is definitely
within the link lists. In another scenario,
let's say I gave you a target of G. And that's
an error, you would just return false because
g is not a value of this linkless. To solve
this one, we're just going to use our classic
linkless traversal algorithm. So we'll step
through it as if we're looking for C. So in
the long run, we expect to get back a true here.
Well, I know that they're going to give me the
head of the linked list as input, and I'll create
a current variable that points to the head node,
of course, I'm going to progressively update this
current variable to be the next node over time,
right? So what I can do is whenever I'm situated
at some current node, I can check if my current
value is equal to my target value. So right now I
would check is a equal to see it's not. And so I
should keep looking through the link lists. I know
that current also has a next property. So I'll
update current to be current dot next, and then I
check is b equal to C? It's not. So I keep going.
And finding that can hit a point where I see that
my current value of c is equal to my target value
of c. And so I can just do an early return true,
right? Once I find a match within my linked lists,
I can just return my final answer. Now let's
say we had the opposite scenario, let's say
that my target was G, we're going to start the
algorithm and the same way we start at current.
And we keep looking through the linked list. And
we set current equal to current next, eventually,
we know that current is going to be equal to null,
which sort of signifies that we've hit the very
end of our link lists, right. And at this point,
once we finish iterating through the entire linked
list, we know that we didn't see the target value
because we were checking the entire way through.
And so at this point, we can do return false.
This is a really practical programming pattern,
right? Where we check some conditional inside of a
loop. And if we find something we're looking for,
we'll return true early. And afterwards, after
our loops done running while return false late.
We talked about this iterative strategy, we know
that if n is the number of nodes, we're just going
to iterate through every node of the linked
list, so we would have a runtime of O of n.
And our space complexity here would just be O of
one because we're just using a constant number of
variables. So That was the iterative solution,
how can you also solve this one recursively.
So let's say we were looking for the target of
C, and we had a more recursive point of view.
So we know we're going to make a top level call
on the head node of our linked lists. And I can
just think about some base cases to use here,
right? And I know I need two base cases, right?
One that can return true, and another that can
return false. So for my first base case, I can
just simply check, alright, if my heads value
is equal to my target, then just return true.
And the opposite scenario, let's say that my
head is no, then I should just return false.
What I always try to do with my recursive code
is the thing about my base cases as if they're
their own valid inputs. So in particular,
for base case number two, if head is null,
then that kind of represents the empty linkless.
If my linked list is empty, then I can return
false because I definitely can't find the target
within an empty linked lists. So how would this
run for current input of targets C? Well, I would
check, alright, is a my target it's not. So I make
a recursive call upon B. Same thing, right? It's
not make another call upon C. And at this point,
I see that my current heads value is equal to my
target. And so this node is going to return the
Boolean true. And I know that this return value is
going to return back to its caller of B. And then
B is going to pass it back up to a and of course,
a returns it to the very, very top level call.
Let's say we had a scenario where a target
was not found within the linked list like G,
then we can see the other base case fire at the
very end, right, so I'm going to make a call on a,
a calls B, B, call C, I still find the value
c calls D. And finally, when D looks at its
next it's going to pass along Nol right,
because these next is technically no. And at
this point, I just hit base case number two,
so I can return false. And like before
I return these values up the call stack.
When we talk about the complexity of this
recursive algorithm, we can say that n is
the number of nodes, we're definitely going to
have O of n runtime, because we make a call for
every node of the link lists. But we also have O
of n space, right? Because each of those calls by
the time we bought them out at a base case, we
would have to store those on the call stack. We
know that the worst case scenario is if our
target is not found within the link lists.
That being said, I think these are two fair
algorithms to go ahead and implement. So give it
a shot on your own. If you get stuck. I'll catch
you in the walkthrough videos. See you there.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right
now I want to go over a JavaScript
solution for this linkless find problem. So we'll
jump right in. And I'll start by showing you all
the iterative solution. And so we'll start with
our pointer variable, we'll say let current equal
the head. And we'll just lay down the foundation,
right? We know we always need to iterate,
while current is not equal to no. And while it's
not know, if we want to progress to the next node
of the link lists, just set current equal to
current dot next. Now I just need to work in
the logic specific to this problem, right. As I
check every current node, I want to see if its
value, so if current dot Val, if that is equal
to my target. And if it's equal to my target,
then I can just return true cuz I found the thing
I'm looking for. What I want to do is return false
only after the while loop, right? It's important
that I return false after the while loop.
Because only after you check every single node of
the linked lists, can you actually confirm that,
hey, the target value is not within the
link lists, what you don't want to do
is write a like if return true, and then else
return false, right, this code would be wrong.
Because let's say you don't find the target
value in the very first note of the linked list,
then you would just incorrectly return false
without even looking at the rest of the linkless.
So none of that we at least want your code
like this. So let's give it a test run,
see what we get. Nice. And there we have our
iterative solution for this linkless find
problem. Let me quickly show you the recursive
version of this, it's going to be very similar.
So in the approach video, if you haven't
watched the approach video recommend you do.
But in the approach video, we mentioned that
we can solve this recursively by just using
two base cases, right? I'll start with the base
case if my head is equal to null, all right, so
that kind of represents the end of my linkless or
also just the empty link lists. So if head is no,
I can't possibly find the target within
an empty link list. So just return false.
Now I need my other base case, right? paid my like
affirmative base case. So if head is not know that
I can look inside of head and I can check if head
dot val is equal to my target, and I've just found
the thing I'm looking for so just return true. So
two base cases here, right? One affirmative and
then one that returns false. But let's say neither
of these are true, right? So my head is not no
and my head value is not equal to my target,
well, then I need to check the rest of the
link list. So here's where I bring in recursion.
And I check the next note. So linkless fine of
head dot next, and you can pass along the same
exact target. So this is going to tell me,
alright is the target found in the next notable
and glass or in the remainder of the link lists.
And I know that this call is going to
return a boolean piece of data, right,
either true or false. I just want to pass that up.
So this should be good to go pretty concise code,
give that a shot. Cool. And there
we have a solution that's recursive.
For this problem. Do you bear in mind when it
comes to the comparison of the complexities?
Technically, we would prefer the iterative
version, right? They both have linear time.
But the iterative version has constant space,
right? I'm just using like a current variable.
Whereas my recursive code uses a linear amount of
space because of the call stack. That being said,
what I want you to do is practice both of these
solutions. And I'll catch you in the next problem.
Hey, programmers, Alan here, right? Now I want to
go over the approach we can use for this get node
value problem. So in this problem, we're going to
take in a linkless. And what we want to do is also
accept an index as input, what we want to do is
really return the nodes value at that given index,
and we will start counting our indices at zero.
In other words, we'll consider the head of our
linked list as having index zero. So for this
particular example, if I asked you for index two
of this linked list, you should return the value
of the C note right? So just return the value
c. And of course, that could be giving you any
particular index as input. So what this question
asks is pretty straightforward. But how can we
go about solving this one. And so what we can do
here is a basic counting algorithm. So we know we
want to return the nodes value, who has index to,
so when we initialize our current pointer to be
the head of the linked list, we'll initialize
our count to zero, then from here, it's just our
classic logic, right? I know I can set current
equal to current dot next. And when I do that,
I'll also increments might count. So now count
is one. Basically, I have tracked the index
of my current node that I'm iterating through
next iteration when current goes to see,
and of course, I increment my count to two.
At this point, I can see that my target index and
my count are equal. And so I can just return the
value within that particular node. But think about
the strategy. It's pretty straightforward in that
if n is the number of nodes, the time complexity
is simply O of n, right? Because in the worst
case, we just have to traverse through the
entire linked lists. We can also say that
the space complexity for this is constant, because
we're just tracking some simple number variables.
So that's how you can solve this one irritably.
How can you also think of this one recursively,
though, so let's reframe our point of view here,
let's say that we were forced to solve this one
recursively. And we know we still want to find
the value at index two. And when I make a call,
I know that the top level caller is going to pass
along the head of the linked list, so the a node,
and also their target index of two, I can use my
classic recursive linkless traversal algorithm. So
I make a recursive call on my next node. When
I make the recursive call on the next node,
what I should also do is pass along the index, but
decrease it by one. So now I'm able to see that,
hey, this current note of B has index one. And if
I keep doing this next iteration, I call upon my
next note of C, and I also decrement, my index
down to zero. Once my index is at zero, that
basically means that I want to return this very
node, right. So if index is equals zero, we'll
return no dot value, that would be our base case.
And once we return that value, I know that I'm
going to return back up the stack. So the c value
returns to its color, and so on and so forth.
Very classic recursive code. So this
looks like a nice recursive algorithm,
we analyze the complexity of this, we're going
to see that the time complexity is still in here.
And the space complexity is actually also linear
here, here, we incur a lot more space complexity,
because we're going to be storing every call upon
the call stack. So what I want you to do is on
your own, try to give it a shot, implement
both the recursive and iterative solutions
for this problem. And if you get stuck,
I'll catch you in the walkthrough videos.
Hey, programmers, welcome back. Right now I want
to go over a JavaScript solution you can use for
this get node value problem. So hopefully,
you already watched the approach video,
if not highly recommend you do that. And we'll
start by implementing maybe that recursive
strategy off the bat. So I'm going to need two
base cases here, like we said in the approach,
and one of them typically is always going to be
if our head is equal to null, that means I've hit
the end of my linked list or I have an empty
linkless. And what I should do is just return
know that we'll actually cover a few scenarios.
If I look at the examples here. Sometimes we may
actually get past a very, very large and Next. So
notice here, they're asking for the value at index
seven. But the link list only has four different
nodes, that means the index of the last node D
would be three, right? 0123. So if ever our target
index is out of range, then we should just return
null. And so this should help me satisfy that,
because I'm going to return no, once I fall off
the edge of the link list. Nice. We're gonna need
another base case, what if we actually find the
particular node that we need to return its value
for. So in over time, I'm going to decrement my
index like we set in the approach. So I can check
if my index is equal to zero, then simply return
this current node, the current node would be
head, dot Val, right, returning its value.
Nice. So bear in mind, we're counting
down here. So in my recursive code,
I need to call my function, get node value,
pass along the next node of the link lists,
and then pass along index minus one. And
I know that this call is going to return
the value of the node at the given index. So I
should just return whatever that comes back. As
I do a quick sanity check here. Bear in mind,
we're counting downwards. So for like this
example, example, 00, we know that A is going
to have an index of two, right technically,
because we're going downward. And when I make the
call for B, it's going to receive index one, when
I call on C, C is going to receive index zero,
which means I should just returned that back up
the stack. So kind of counting downwards here in
the reverse. But this should be a nice solution.
Let's give us a test run. Bear in mind, this
solution has a linear time complexity and also a
linear space complexity, we can actually cut down
on the space if we write the iterative version.
So I'll show you that right now. So the intro
translation, you should be very familiar with
probably wondering, why are we doing such simple
problems? Well, it's about to get more difficult,
right? To me, it's all about the foundations.
So our classic strategy is for iterations, set
your current variable to be the head node, right,
I'll just lay out the classic traversal. So while
my current is not equal to no, then keep on going
to progress to the next node in the sequence,
what I should do is set current equal to current
dot next. And now I need to work in the problem
specific logic here, right? I know I want to
return the node at the given index. And for
these iterative patterns, all counts upwards.
So I'll set some count variable equal to zero,
just like this. And whenever I progress
to the next node of the linkless,
all set count plus equals one. So I'm counting
upward. So when I get to some point when my count
is equal to my target index, and I can just return
this node, right, so I can return this nodes
value. So again, we're counting upward in the
air diversion, whereas in the recursive version,
be counted downward. Nice. Let's go ahead and run
this code. There was one thing that probably won't
pass, but we'll give it a go. See what happens.
So I'm getting an error here, get node value
has already been declared, because of course, I
have it defined twice. So we'll try that again,
can't read declare your const variables. So
we'll run it. And we're failing test 02, which is
the test where our index or a target
index is too large. So here's 02.
So we should have our function return null. If
we can't find the node at the specified index,
right now we're returning undefined, which is
happening because this while loop is actually
ending, right, we're going to hit the very, very
tail of our link lists. And so our while loops
over and we're just going to hit line 16. When
we fall off the edge of our function evaluation,
we're just going to by default, return undefined.
So to fix this, it's quite straightforward,
just by default, return null. And that should
satisfy that scenario. Let's give it a run there.
Cool. And there, we have an iterative solution.
So for this iterative solution, it has a linear
time complexity, just like the recursion, but
it has a better space complexity right here,
we consider this constant space, because we
only use a handful of variables, like current
and count. That being said, what I want you to
do is practice both of these implementations,
because in the next few problems, it's going to
get a little more involved. I'll see you there.
Hey, programmers, welcome back. Right now let's
go over an approach we can use for this reverse
list problem. So in this problem, we're going
to take in a linked list that's input. What
we want to do here is actually reverse the order
of the nodes in this link lists. So if our input
list contains the values ABCD in place, meaning we
want to mutate the existing linked list in place,
we want to actually change the order to DC ba just
ending up with the link list. in reverse order.
In this function, what we should do is also return
the new head of the linked list. So technically,
your function for this input should return the D
node. So let's come up with a strategy we can use
to solve this one. When it comes to the tools we
can use for a linked list, we know more or less,
we always have to iterate or traverse through
the entire link lists. And we know that that
requires at least one pointer. Typically, we
call it current. The trick here is actually use
multiple variables. So let's say I began my
classic current pointer pointing at the head
of the link lists. What I'll also need is to
track the previous node I visited at the start,
because I haven't visited any other nodes, we
can make this previous pointer point to know.
And we know this entire time, if I have access
to current, I also have access to the next node
in the list right by just accessing current
dot next, we're just going to label that as
a temporary variable here. And we'll call
it next. And you'll see why in a little bit.
So I know I need to have the long term effect of
just reversing all of the next pointers in this
link list. In other words, I need to make a point
to know. And so what I can do is literally just
set current dot next, in other words, setting
the arrow to point to previous ending up with
this. Now it should be abundantly clear why
we saved the B node with that next variable,
because once we reroute current dot next to point
to No, we would lose access if we didn't have
that next variable. So what I can do now is
shift my point of view, I can set my current
to be the next and set my previous to be the
old current just shifting my point of view,
like this. And now I can set current dot next
to be the previous node once again, rerouting
this pointer. And this process continues.
As we get toward the end of the link list,
we have to also remember is technically since D
is the old tail of the linkless. This entire time,
it actually did have a next pointer
just happened to point to know.
And so at this point, I can actually continue
my general algorithm right, I still set
current dot next to my previous rerouting this
pointer. And I can actually continue one more
iteration. If I set current to be the next, it's
now the case that current is actually at null,
which means we hit the end of our linked list
and we can stop our algorithm. If we look at
the current state of our linked lists, it
is in reverse order, right D points to see
points to B points to a points to null. So things
are good to go there. And if I wanted to return
the new head of the link lists, I can simply
return the final value of the previous variable.
So that actually works out pretty elegant.
If we do the analysis for this algorithm,
if we implement this in an iterative way, and we
say n is the number of nodes, we know that the
runtime is just going to be O of n, really just
traversing through the entire linked list once
we can say that the space complexity is constant,
because we only need a fixed number of variables.
So overall, this is a maximum efficient algorithm
to reverse a linked list. When we go on to the
code walkthrough for this, I'll actually show you
how to implement this iteratively and recursively.
Bearing in mind that the recursive would actually
suffer a slightly worse space complexity. But
before we get there, try to give this a shot
on your own implement this if you get stuck,
I'll catch you in the walkthrough video. See
you there. Hey, programmers, welcome back.
Right now I want to go over a JavaScript solution
we can use for this reverse list problem.
So hopefully already watched the approach video,
if not, I highly recommend it, because we're gonna
implement that strategy pretty closely. So I'll
start with the iterative version here. And we
know we just need to lay down at least initially,
our classic linkless traversal is just going to
keep my current variable initialize that to head
and loop while my current is not equal to no.
And I know that the basic code would always be set
current equal to current dot next, that would just
move sequentially through the linked lists. But
we need to work in a few other variables, right.
So the key here is to have some variable, we'll
call it previous and to initialize it equal to
null. And if we were wondering why null is a great
default value for this previous, just think about
what needs to happen on the very, very first
iteration of our while loop. So we know that
our current is going to be a, and in the long run,
we know A's next needs to actually point to No,
right because he needs to become the tail.
So if we initialize previous with no,
on the first iteration, we can immediately just
say current dot next, equals previous right,
that would actually have that arrow
point to null, which is good to go.
But then at this point, we need to make sure
that we have some proper references here.
So before we just reassign current dot next,
if we just overrode it, willy nilly, then we
would lose access to whatever the actual next note
sequentially was. So I'll save that to a variable.
I'll say maybe const next, equals current dot
next, and then after I override it, I can still
make progress to the next node of the linked
lists. by simply setting current equal to next,
awesome. So that's looking pretty good. And not
only do I need to progress current, but previous
should now also point to current shifting my full
point of view. So some pretty tricky logic over
here. Let's go ahead and maybe analyze a little
bit closer, what it's doing, please mask er here.
So let's say we had a link list
that looked like this A points to B
points to see, we know we have initially current
over here, right, so current is pointing to a,
we know that when I save that next variable, it's
going to point to this B over here. So I'll save
that. And technically at the very start, we
initialize previous to be null. So I'll just
use like capital n represent null. And I know
previous is going to point to that like this.
Awesome. So on the first iteration, we
have all these variable setup and I set
current dot next equal to previous current dot
next is represented by this arrow. So when I say
current dot next to be previous, it has this
visual representation, right, just setting it
the opposite direction, once I do, they would
actually lose this arrow. And now you can probably
see why we saved next for B, right, that way, you
don't lose access to the rest of the link list.
Cool. At this point, I can set some variables,
right, I can make previous, the current,
so I'll set it like this, then I also set
current to the next. So basically just shift over
the point of view. And if you look at the state
of my drawing, now, things are actually perfectly
aligned. For the next iteration, I would just set
current next to be previous once again, and so on
and so forth all the way through the very end of
the link list. And like we said in the approach,
once we actually end when current is equal to
null, you exit the while loop, and previous would
actually contain the new head of the link list.
So I'm just going to return previous over here,
it doesn't make sense that previous would be the
new head of the link list. Because after exit the
while loop, I know previous is going to be the
original tail, right? If I'm reversing the tail
becomes a head, and vice versa. Cool. So really
just a spin off of our classic linkless traversal,
I will tell you that the logic here can get pretty
tricky, especially with these temporary variables.
So we'll give it a test run, see what we get.
And hopefully, we'll have this nice O of n
runtime o of one space solution. Awesome. There we
have it. And so what I'll also do now is show you
the recursive version, it will have a slightly
worse space complexity, although the code is
noticeably more concise. So I think it's still
worth practicing. So really, we're just going
to translate the same premise into its recursive
version, right. So I'm going to still need like
access to two variables, or two pointers. And the
way I establish that recursively is by using a
default argument here. So I'll set previous equal
to null. So if you're unfamiliar in JavaScript,
this is how you just do a default argument. Right.
So if someone does not pass in a second argument,
when they call reverse list, by default,
it's going to be set to null. And I can
start with the classic base case, right? If head
is null, then I've hit the end of my linked list.
And what I can do is actually just returned
previous for the same reason I returned previous
over here, right previous would actually be
the new tail. And when it comes to actually
writing the recursive code, I'm just going
to try my best to translate all of these
iterative patterns into their recursive analogues.
So I'm going to save a reference to the head next,
just a temporary variable. Because if I override
it by saying head dot next equals previous,
I would lose access to it otherwise. So now
I at least have a way to call recursively
and traverse through the rest of the link list.
So passing next, as the new head and pass in
head as the new previous, really just
shifting that point of view, once again,
I think about the return value for verse
list, I know it's going to return a node,
right, it's going to return hopefully, the new
head of the linkless. So I just want to pass up
that return value, do stay aware in this problem,
they say your function should return the new head
of the reverse link list. And this should
actually satisfy that. So we'll give this a run.
Nice. And here we have a O of n time
recursive solution that is also O of n space,
right? So apples to apples comparison, if
you want it to get the most efficiency,
you should prefer the iterative version.
That being said, I still think there's a
nice value to practicing both of these. And this
is actually a pretty common interview problem.
So make sure you have this down pat. Before we
hop into the next problem. I'll see you there.
Hey programmers, Alvin here, right now I want to
go over the approach we can use for the Zipperless
problem. So in this problem, we're going to take
in two linkless, whatever Want to do is zipper
these two lists together. In other words, I need
to in place, reassign all of these next pointers
such that we alternate between the nodes of list
one and list two. And also looks like we should
always start with the first note of list one. And
then from that point on simply alternate. That
being said, let's take a look at another example.
We don't have many assumptions we can use when it
comes to the length of both of our lists, except
that we know that each list is actually non empty.
But besides that, what if one of my lists was
longer than the other? Well, then what I want
to do is alternate as much as I can, and then
just terminate the link lists with the remaining
nodes. Soon as I alternate with AQ br, at which
point I don't have any more nodes in the list too.
So I just take all of the remaining nodes
of list one and add them to the very end.
And so we'll want to keep that edge case in mind
when we come up with a strategy for this one.
So where do we even start with a problem like
this? Well, you should be familiar with our core
linkless pattern, right? We just know how to
traverse sequentially through a link lists.
And so what I can do is actually maintain
two pointers at a time right? One for list
one and another for list two. So let's say
we started stepping through this example.
I know I'm past both of these head nodes, head one
and head two respectively. And then from there,
I can set up some respective current pointers.
And so given in the examples, we always want
to start with the head node of list one. So I'm
just going to start that down here. And what I'll
need to do is also track the tail of my output
list, right? Although we're just reassigning
all of our pointers in place, we're going to
need a reference. That way, we can figure out
how we can add new nodes to our current output,
we'll say. And since I already begin my chain with
the first node of list one, then I need
to be sure that I actually progress
current one. And so current one should really be
pointing at this B node. And so now that I have
at least a starting node, how can I come up with
a general algorithm here? Well, if you want to
establish a simple alternating pattern, then what
you can do is just use a counter variable haven't
started zero. And then based on whether or not
the count is even or odd, that would tell you from
which list you should take your next node. And so
since I already began with a node from list one,
what I should do is whenever my count is even,
I'm going to grab a node from lists to when count
is odd, I'm going to grab a node from list one.
So right now count is 00 is technically an even
number. And so I'm going to take my next node from
list two. So I look at my current two pointer,
and it tells me I should just take that cue
node and add it as the next of my tail. And
so now that I've consumed a node from list two, I
need to be sure I progress current to to its next,
just like this. And I also need to make progress
on some other pointers here, I need to progress
my tail also to its next, that way, I can get
set up for the next iteration of the algorithm.
At this point, I need to increment my count by
one. So now count is one. Since my count is odd,
I should take a node from list one. So I look at
my current one pointer, and I add b to the tail,
just like this. And I make progress on all of
my variables, right. So I'm going to progress
current one, I'm going to progress my tail
and increment my count to two. Since it's even
now I should take a note from list two. So I take
my AR from current two. And when I set current two
to its next, it's going to become No, when I set
tail to its next, it's going to be set to the r,
and then I increment my count. So now my count
is three. And now I have an important scenario,
it looks like I've exhausted all of the nodes
in list two, we spoke about this scenario,
right? Whenever we finish all of the nodes
of one of our lists, we should just terminate
our output with all the remaining nodes
of our other list the non empty list.
And so at this point, what I can
do is just take my current one,
basically this C chain and everything after it,
and just put it after the tail in my output,
just like this. And of course, I want to complete
the connection over here. And this would actually
be the correct output. And so overall strategy
was to maintain pointers to both of our respective
link lists, and maintain accounts, right,
depending on whether the count is even or odd,
then that'll tell me from which list I should
take my next node. And along with that, we also
need to maintain some tail pointer we can use. So
we can actually build up the linked list output.
Let's talk about the complexity of this one. Since
we have two linked lists as input to this problem,
we should probably use two terms to describe
its complexity. So if I say n is the length
of list one, and I say m is the length of
list two that I can say the time complexity
is the minimum between n and m. Recall that
when we just step through this algorithm,
we really only needed as many iterations as the
shorter linkless. Recall the algorithm we just
traced through. Now once we hit the end of one
of our link lists, we know we just finished the
algorithm by taking the remaining nodes of the
other list and just tack it on to the end. And
that finishing step only takes an O of one time,
surely, as soon as one of our linkless runs out,
which will always be in general, the shorter one,
then I can just finish my algorithm, I actually
don't have to iterate fully through both of them.
And I would still consider this technically, you
know, some form of a linear runtime. For the space
complexity, you can see how the space here is just
constant, right? We're not actually creating any
new nodes, we're simply rerouting all of these
next pointers. And in terms of our variables, we
only use a fixed number of them. And so overall,
this seems like a reasonable strategy, what I want
you to do is try to code up this one on your own,
it's going to be some really interesting
code, a new pattern for us that is,
and if you get stuck, I'll catch you in
the walkthrough videos. See you there.
Hey, programmers, Alan here, right now I want
to go over a JavaScript solution for this
Zipperless problem. So we'll jump right in,
hopefully watch the approach video. And we'll
start with an iterative version of this, the
way we're going to attack this one is by doing
our classic linkless traversal. But do it twice
over for a head one and head two simultaneously,
really. So I'll set my let current one, start
at head one. And I'll also set let current to
the start at head two. And I'm going to need
my main loop just to iterate through the
linkless. Second check, while current one
is not no. And current two is not at all.
So notice, as soon as one of my linkless hits
its end, this loop would actually stop, right?
Cool, we want to be sure to do is set up also a
way to create the output. So look at the prompt,
we always start with the first node of
list one. So in this particular example,
I'm zippering, ABC and XYZ, I always start
with the a here. And we're going to use
that to get the ball rolling on my resulting
list, we're not going to create any new nodes.
But we do have to rewire all of these next
pointers. So what I'll say is maybe, let's
say head over here, and this will be the head
of our output, because I know I need to return
that by the end, something like that, I'm going
to start head really as head one, technically,
and then current one will actually have to start
one after that, like we said in the approach.
So I'll set current one equal to we'll say,
head dot next, that'll be a good starting
point from there. And in addition to having this
a head pointer, that's because I want to return,
you know, the new head of billing class, which
I guess would be the same as head one as I think
of it. So maybe we don't need this variable. But
we do need is a pointer that we can append after,
right. So I'm going to say left tail, I think
as a matter of fact, when I set tail equal to
head one, say no head, one's going to be
the first note in my output. And over time,
I need to add things after the tail building up
my resulting list. So that's looking pretty good.
Now we'll go ahead and increment our counter,
add that into the mix here. So we'll say
let count beginning at zero. And dependent on
whether or not our count is even or odd, that can
tell me whether I should take a node from list one
or list two. So I think we're ready to hop into
our main code over here. I know I should end any
particular iteration by of course, incrementing,
the count, right? Count plus equals one, I'm just
going to put that down there. So I don't forget.
And I will start by checking the parody of that
count, right whether or not it's even or odd,
so I'll simply check if count mod two is
equal to zero, right, so that means it's even
an else it's odd. So bear in mind, I started my
output list with a note from head one from list
one. And initially, I start my count equal
to zero. So I guess when my count is zero,
I'll take something from list two. So what I can
do is take whatever current two is pointing at,
so current two, and I want to make that the next
of the tail, right tail is helping me build the
output. So simply tail dot next equals current
to nice. Then from there, since I just used up
something from list to I need to progress that so
current to equals current to dot next. And I know
that this code over here, when it's odd, it's
going to be symmetric, just for current one.
And in addition to that, we need to make sure that
we also move our tail pointer that's going gonna
happen in either scenario. So I can put that
mutual code over here, I think I'll say tail
equal tail dot next. Nice. So this should help me
construct my alternating pattern. But we have to
worry about is based on my while loop, this while
loop is going to terminate or end, as soon as one
of my current pointers hits null. And it could
be the case that only one of them is null, and
the other one is still pointing to some data. And
like we said, in the approach, what we should do
is just tack on all of the nodes of the other list
to our final output here. So what I'll do is I'll
check here, right? If, let's say, current one
foot still has stuff, so it's not equal to know
that I can just take that stuff and add it to
the tail. So tail dot next equals current one.
And symmetric for current two, of course. So
I'd look at the prompt over here, we're thinking
about a scenario like this one right here, we know
that current one is way longer than current two,
or list one is longer than list two. And so by the
time we get to the end of list two, we know that
roughly we're going to be at about this C node or
this D node in list one, we just want to take all
those remaining elements looks like D, and add
it to the end of that list. Notice I just end in
DEF. Cool, and we just need to check both
sides of that. Awesome, I think at this point,
let's give this a nice test run. Gonna always
debug it together. It's not too long of some code,
but it does have some interesting patterns.
Awesome. Here, we have a nice iterative solution
for Zipperless. For this code, we're looking
at linear runtime, and constant space. And so
I think what we'll do is, let me also show
you how you could solve this one recursively.
It's very similar and strategy, somewhat shorter
code. I'll leave it to you whether or not you
think it's more simple or not. We will have to
concede, though, that for any recursive code,
especially for this one, we're going to have some
additional stack space used. So we would have
a linear space for recursion as well. So
I'm going to do my best to translate these
patterns. So I know I should stop my recursion
will say if head one is no, and head two is no.
So that's very similar to what we just said
in our iterative version. And if there are no,
then you kind of at the end, you can just
return null. What I have to be sure I do is
for my function needs to return like the new head
of the linkless. And so I'll just have some base
case here, where I return null is basically a
linked list contains like many sub lists, right?
What you should be doing as you solve linkless
problems. Recursively is, if you think of let's
say this as a linked list, going from A through
Z, then going from x to z is also linked lists
going from B to Z is also a linked list. So
that's how I kind of break down my problem size.
So if they're both null, then return null. But
what if only one of them isn't? All right. So what
if head one is no. All right? And that would mean
if head one is the only one, that's all that means
had to have some stuff, well then just return
the remainder of had to make that symmetric for
the other side, right? So we've had two is nil.
And had one isn't, then just return the remainder
have had one. And what this base case or these
base cases will let me do is accomplish some
logic, just like this, right? How can I take
all of the leftover nodes in the case of one
of my lists running out and just tack it on to
the end? Right, if one of my pointers runs out,
I'm just gonna return the other pointer. Cool,
which would be the leftover chain. Now I need my
recursive code. So there are a few ways you can
write this. Instead of using the modular trick and
checking for even or odd, what I should be able to
do is take two notes at a time here. So let's say
I know I need to make my head head one, really. So
I'm going to return head one, I think at the end,
and I need to make head one dot next
point two, whatever had to is, right.
And as soon as I do that, I would actually
lose access to the original head one next,
so I should have saved that. So I'll
say maybe const. Next one equals had one
dot next before I overwrite it. And I guess why
not. While we're here we'll also do the same for
next to pretty common thing we have to do for a
linkless problems right before you overwrite a
pointer, maybe save it in case you need it still.
So I'm making head one next point to head to
and then from there. I know I need to
call recursively zipper list on next one.
And also, next to it should be right. And then
from here, I just chained head one to two. I
know Zipperless is going to return In the head of
the remaining linkless, I just need to chain that
to head to so had to dot next equals that return
value, because again, I'm going to return a
node from this recursive call. So this code is
looking pretty good. Let's go ahead and test it,
it is quite a bit shorter. So we're getting error
Zipperless is not defined. Because I s here,
that's on me. Give that a go again. little
typo there. Nice. And here, we have a nice
recursive solution for this. And so just
to make sure we're on the same page here,
maybe it's worth stepping through at least one
iteration together. And so let's say I had these
lists had ABC and XYZ, trace through at least
one stack frame of this. So ABC, and then x,
y, z. Alright, so I know in the context of
my pointers, I have h1 over here, right,
that's going to be head one. They also have head
two, of course, so h2 over here. And what I do is,
I'm not hitting the base cases for this, because
I have two nodes. And so we save some pointers to
their next. So nothing fancy here, I have next
one over here, I have next to over here. And in
the core logic of actually alternating, what I do
is I take head ones dot next and point it to head
to. So I don't want to just kind of merge them
together in line over here. So kind of separately,
although you know, I'm not creating new
nodes would look like this head one is a,
I said it's next to x. So that already looks good
to go. And then from there, I set head twos next
to whatever the recursive call is, when I pass
along, next one next to so at this point, I can
kind of ignore these. Right? So I'll take out just
this a node. And now h one, or head one points to
be the same thing over here. H two points to y.
And let's say we step through this iteration,
well, same thing. I just take head one,
and I know I'm going to return head one,
right? So eventually it's going to return over
here. It's going to say B points to why, right?
Because head one is B h two is wine head one
that next equals head two, and that's good to go.